Casey is with us in Ohio
hi Casey welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
all right thank you guys to take your
next fall sure what's up
no it's not they are trying to figure
out what to do about my vehicle which is
a truck I hate to admit that I took a
loan out look I like it and play with
cash or time we are starting to do the
baby steps and pay off our debt okay
currently and I bought a $7,000 truck
and it turned out to be a bit of a lemon
and I owe 5,000 left on the truck and
I've already paid around $3,000 and
repairs with right now everything I'm
just so worried about keeping it and
keep paying at all or try and sell it
and possibly we would have to take a
loan out for another car but I believe I
would qualify for a year-personal loan
anyway for right now I want what I want
what kind of a 0% loan are you talking
about um there for like a six month or
six year of a five-year 0% oh you're
talking about a brand-new Club
yeah yeah so you would move from a
$5,000 car to a 25,000 our car yeah 2000
yeah that'd be real stupid yeah when you
get married next next May a year from
now okay yeah what do you okay so
there's not there's not a we until May
you don't you don't combine your
finances with someone you're not married
to that'll get both of you in trouble
and cause you to hate each other don't
do that so what do you make 60,000 a
year okay what other debts do you have
other than your trough I just oh good
well you've done a really good job other
than you picked out a bad truck right
yeah if you don't have
that much dad you got $8,000 for the
debt you make 60 grand we can clean this
up so I don't mind you selling the truck
cause you think it's a piece of crap and
I don't doubt it is I kind of think
you're probably right
but I would buy something equal or less
and let's just get it paid off don't
fall for the I'm gonna go deeper in debt
because it's 0%
because even with 0% there are payments
you know that right yeah yeah you do not
need to move up in car you need to dump
the truck and get something about the
same price range
and then say I make 60,000 and way
before next May the 3,000 our credit
card and the $5,000 car note are paid
off and you're debt-free coming into
marriage I like that yeah I like that
that's what I want you to do brother
okay and she's already said she'll marry
you so doesn't matter how cool your
truck yes
you don't have to have a cool truck
anymore because you already got you're
done you're done very cool
hey man thanks for the call that's how I
knew my wife loved me man my car cost
$1,000 and I bought from some guy that
my dad knew at the church and man there
was never a question a thousand thousand
bucks dollars well I'm kind of car was
it was an 88 Toyota Tercel easy
hatchback not that I remember it and my
buddies call it the roller skate because
I'm a big dude and I could barely it was
like a like a barely Winstone's car I'm
Toyota Tercel hatchback yes with how
many months I think you kind of stopped
at some point just somewhere around
300,000 lay down and it called it and
what color was just wonderful V it was a
it couldn't have been a more manly Texas
light blue color yeah man it just
screamed that guy's he's a Texan all
through and it just expected to got to
get out with a big belt buckle all day
long not and cowboy boots yeah I knew
she loved me for me Dave she was
marrying wheelers for the cool ride
there's always that test oh man the
tercel test the tercel test so I was
even worse sharing in our dating and she
didn't have a car my little sister put
her car up for sale and I bought it for
$750 boy
it was a straight shift Pinto dude my
Tercel would have smoked your
yes-yes-yes-yes been awesome this would
have been in contest too ugly and you
know we're not sure which one I'm gonna
want straight [ __ ] I mean this thing a
motorcycle engine in the under the hood
started with a rope yeah hold on it's
good oversharing I got it was straight
[ __ ] and you're not old enough to
remember this but there was a whole
thing on 60 minutes right about that
time where they had a defect in the gas
tank anytime they got hit from behind
they blew up everybody inside the
blow-up mobile you can show them my
buddies are like you really don't like
her got her at this car and so yeah we
got engaged and I got her a big-time car
and and she stuck it out she's doing all
better in cars now my wife hasn't moved
up much from her cell we're getting
there honey I promise I promise we're
gonna get there man hears that the truth
is though you should have a story of a
car that needs a name
from the time when you were broke mm-hmm
and when you're eight thousand dollars
in debt you don't have any money you
make sixteen you're getting ready to get
married that's the time when you were
broke mm-hmm and it's it's if you don't
have that story it means you tried to
circumvent that by going and get a
$20,000 car was 0% loan and he's trying
to solve a $5,000 debt with a $20,000
debt right yeah yeah exactly
well he's trying to see what he's sick
and tireless typical truck breaking down
fair enough registration fair that's
what's driving it but you should and
sometimes if you if you have to take a
penalty step back to the car that needs
a name to get on solid ground and to get
out drive like no one else so that later
you can drive like no one else we are
you know for years I've been trying to
teach people quit saying the junk car is
your Dave car mmm that's insulting I
look out in the parking lot in your
parking spot
yeah there's that's not a car that's a
Dave car out there my parking spot now
that's
what you get afterwards right you know
if you drive like no one else later you
get to drive your Dave car which is the
dream car a stupid tax car not the David
are cool